since you've
pondered some big ridiculous questions
in your work
what's the meaning of this whole thing
what's the meaning of life wow human
life
well
as far as i know
we're unique in the the universe there's
no evidence that there's anything else
in the universe that's as complicated as
what's between our ears
might be you can't rule it out but
um
so we appear to be pretty special and um
so it's got to have something to do with
that and one of the reasons i like
david deutsch
in particular his book the beginning of
infinity
um
is that he talks about the power of
explanations
and the fact that um
most
civilizations are static that they've
got a set of dogmas that they arrive at
somehow
and they just pass those on from one
generation to the next and nothing
changes
but that
huge changes have happened
when people sort of
follow and whatever you want to call it
the scientific method or enlightenment
uh
there's different ways of thinking about
it but basically explanatory
it's it's about the power of
explanations
and being able to figure out why things
are the way they are
and that has created changes in our
thinking in our way of life over the
last few centuries that are
explosive compared to anything that came
before
and david sort of verges on
classifying this as like a force of
nature
in its potential transformative power
if we keep going
um
you know we could uh
you know if we figure out how to
colonize the universe
like you were talking about earlier
how this spread to other star systems
then it is
effectively a force of nature
this kind of drive to understand more
and more and more deeper and deeper and
deeper
and to engineer stuff so that we can
understand even more yeah
yeah it's the
well it's the old the universe created
us to understand itself maybe that's the
uh
the whole purpose
yeah
it's it is an interesting peculiar side
effect
of the way we've been created is we seem
to be conscious beings we seem to have
little egos we seem to
uh be born and die pretty quickly
there's a bunch of drama we're all
within ourselves
pretty unique and we fall in love and
start wars and there's hate and all the
the full interesting dynamic of it so
it's not just about the individual
people
yeah somehow like the concert that we
played together mm-hmm
yeah yeah
so
that's kind of interesting and there's a
lot of peculiar aspects of that that um
i wonder if they're fundamental or just
quirks of evolution
whether it's whether it's death whether
it's love whether all those things i
wonder if they're um
from an engineering perspective when
we're trying to create that intelligent
toaster that listens for the
for the slam door
and this and the smell of burning toast
whether uh that toaster should be afraid
of death and should fall in love just
like we do
neil
you're a fascinating human being you've
impacted the lives of millions of people
it's a huge honor that you would spend
your valuable time with me today thank
you so much thank you for coming down
uh
beautiful hot texas
and thank you for talking today it was a
pleasure i'm glad i came and did it
you